[Music]
let's get started
so I am very excited to be here today to
talk to you all with Andrew Fikes
who is the VP and engineering fellow at
Google and I'll let him introduce
himself and then I'll go and talk to you
about Who I am okay well first off
welcome I'm excited to see everyone here
today I was promised an intimate talk in
an intimate setting with just a few
small number of people this is amazing
this is really exciting to me I've
worked in the database distributed
database space for a long time and
seeing this meeting people there is
excited about storage as I am which is
the hard thing to do super geeky about
it so I'm excited you're here
first off just a little bit about myself
I've been at Google 18 years this is the
only job I've ever had I came right out
of school and went into Google so I've
kind of grown up in the Google culture
I've grown up sort of learning things
from the ground up
I was the tech lead of the BigTable team
we have our external product the cloud
BigTable which I worked on for many many
years
Tech League the spanner team threw most
of its initial development and the last
three years I've served in a role which
is we call area tech lean which covers
in my case both storage and databases
and I cover basically tech lead role for
everything from the disks at the bottom
to a little bit of the networking in
between all the way to the distributed
databases at the top so I know quite a
bit about the distributed database space
and I know a little bit about everything
else so I'm hopefully I will be able to
answer a bunch of questions that you'll
have today and give you a little
perspective about engineering at Google
thank you Andrew
my name is VP Shrivastav I am the
product manager for cloud spanner my
entire tenure at Google has been in
spanner so it's a few more years than
three before that I was at work working
in the rack database kernel and before
that I was researching distributed
systems and I actually never thought
that databases were cool
because that's 30 year old technology
right who cares I had the same problem I
never took a database class in college
because I never wanted to work on
databases here we are and it's been a
very exciting journey I worked with
Andrew to launch spanner internally and
the Chris is here there are some chris
is here too to launch spanner internally
as a service and spanner has been
running internally as a service managing
a bunch of critical infrastructure for
like over seven years and it was my
noogler project to launch it so it's
very exciting for me personally to talk
about the history and journey of spanner
with Andrew before we go further there
is a mic here unfortunately we have only
one mic so as you have questions if you
could maybe make your way there and if
you want to shout it out from where you
are we'll try and not change your
question and repeat it an answer so
let's get started okay so first I get to
do my what is cloud spanner so for those
who don't know cloud spanner is one of
our database offerings on Google's cloud
platform
it is basically the same infrastructure
as internal spanner and it's exposed by
the cloud API so that's the difference
in sort of the access path is different
but it it was essentially a
differentiated service on cloud on
Google cloud because it combines the
benefits of relational semantics with
non relational or no sequel horizontal
scale so we call it our no compromises
database in that you don't have to
compromise between schemas and sequel
and strong consistency and asset
transactions and this the global scale
that you get with spanner so today's
talk is really about how this this
awesome for I love this product I call
myself a database person now through my
journey with spanner so how did this
system come about both the sort of
technical history as well as some of the
people history around it and this is
what we offer essentially externally on
the Google cloud
that one so Andrew what came before
spanner so when I start to tell the
spanner story I think it's sort of
important to think about where Google
was at that time right so essentially
where we were in about 2007 2008 as a
company Google historically started as a
search company an overtime groove to be
an ads company a mobile company a geo
company I'm probably forgetting mobile a
few different things like that and
eventually a cloud company but around
that 2008 time we really had kind of an
interesting set of infrastructure
internally we were a large my sequel
database shop on our ad side of the
world we ran about 90 database shards
and AD kind of a home built query system
that worked across them so we were
dealing with sort of large-scale
distributed partitioned my sequel
instances we were also a very big
BigTable shop at that time so we started
BigTable I want to say 2003 2004
somewhere in there and it was really
focused on the search landscape right we
wanted to build a big table that had as
its primary key the URL of a web page
and then its columns would be the actual
documents and PageRank and other sorts
of things on the other columns so we had
a my sequel shop and we had a big table
shop we were also however starting to
become an Apps company right so we all
know and love and use G suite today but
there was a time when Gmail was kind of
a smaller product and so as Google was
starting to become a calendar company a
drive your company and these sorts of
things we were starting to get these
needs of more complex applications being
built on top of our infrastructure and
so we really that was kind of the kind
of the ecosystem we had at that time
yeah do you had touch upon Megastore at
all right so Megastore was kind of our
first foray into something that looked
close to spanner and it was an
application library that was built on
top of BigTable that actually did use
Paxos that provided a much smaller kind
of data partition sort of a what we call
him the MTT crew and it was rolled as a
client library
so you had to link it into your client
and you had to deal with client
semantics on top of BigTable yeah so
there's a paper on BigTable if you care
there's a paper in mega story if you
care and you know as these products
evolved like we know we can catch up on
the journey and if you thought that we
weren't gonna get technical I think we
have gotten that so what prompted the
need to both span our given we had
awesome BigTable that engendered a bunch
of other no sequel systems outside and
we had Megastore which was almost banner
yeah I mean I think you know the most
obvious thing was was sort of scale and
scale with these applications with
things like Gmail right where we were
starting to think about okay Gmail is in
three data centers for example well what
happens if Gmail gets too big for a data
center right how do we split it up how
do we manage the geographies that are
associated with users right we had a
large user base on these applications
that was developing in Europe and in
other countries and we didn't want them
to have the same latency semantics as
the people in the US so we were really
thinking about this this sharding
concept right so we were really
interested in that that kind of Gio
concept we are also starting to really
think about the importance of
consistency and what it actually means
to have a consistent system and how it
impacts our developers and our users and
our productivity and velocity and so
that was sort of coming around in there
interestingly enough right around this
time we decided that 90 shards was
enough my sequel shard that we had
restarted it and every restarting was a
couple of years and we've kind of
thought if we were gonna do it again
maybe we should think about whether or
not we should do something different we
really had sort of the growth of the
apps and this interest in consistent
replication transactions and and those
sorts of things because users actually
do notice inconsistencies and we also
had this growth on on the ads sort of
more financial database side to just
really be able to scale to the enormous
business that Google was developing yeah
you sons so Andrews being very modest
like the ads database is how Google used
to make money so it was really important
that we didn't spend two years plus
every time you know rashard and I don't
know how many people here remember when
Gmail was like you could get five
friends like if you if you had a gmail
account that you could get five friends
to get a gmail account so that scale of
like going from whatever some number of
users to 7 billion accounts or whatever
it is today that's truly like the scale
and the time that we're talking about
here so before we go into that stuff
deeper did you get it right the first
time right so so one thing I hear a lot
is you know how did you come up with
this great idea like you know you
publish these papers they're sort of you
know seminal like what's the process and
I think what people miss a lot
externally is we spent years getting it
wrong so we actually started thinking
about spanner and split off a chunk of
people from BigTable to work on it and I
think we built and Chris can probably
attest three or four different systems
over two and a half or three years
before we landed on the one that that we
ended up with we had some horrible
mistakes you know one version of spanner
actually supported recursive directories
and we had our PC operations that could
do recursive descent on directories and
as you can kind of see that's really
really far away from their relational
model the good news is is that when the
ads team came to us we sort of got our
hands on a real customer that we were
trying to work with and when people
asked me how do you how do you decide to
build infrastructure I think it starts
with a really good customer and for us
that that really good customer was the
ads database yeah customers first so
let's get into a little bit of the
details and talk about you know how is
spanner built sort of what other
building blocks if you could talk to us
about that we have an awesome picture
here that you can talk about but I think
that picture is super cool Wow
so so one of the great things about
building infrastructure at Google is you
start with like a really great set of
resources so this is a really good
example of sort of what it's like to
build infrastructure in our cloud these
basically show our network lines one of
the gifts that we have as engineers is
that our internal networks within the
data center are phenomenally good I
haven't really worried about networking
performance networking loss for a really
long time and as a storage person that
means you can take a whole set of things
and just set it aside and you can think
about the algorithms and things that lay
on top that same internal experience we
get across across you know large spans
as well right we have three redundant
lines out of data centers we have
extremely high availability being able
to depend on that level from your
network really simplifies a lot of your
distributed system building and I know
it says it there but anyway the the blue
dots are basically where GCP so Google
Cloud has presence externally as well as
the number indicates sort of how many
availability zones there are and how
they're all connected by a Google Fiber
essentially so to andrew's point when
customers asked me like well what will
the latency be like for this globally
distributed massive thing I'm like not
very much like they're like how do you
go over man and like we're like we don't
have to go over a public internet for
the most part so so that's super awesome
I wonder if you want to touch upon
Colossus before we go - yeah so so I you
know I think the other area we've always
really depended on is we do have a very
large scale distributed file system that
sits as sort of the basis of all of our
artists our distributed storage systems
we published a paper on GFS which was
the very first version of that I think
probably in 2002-2003
the one we use now today is actually
called Colossus and it basically
occupies you know many many megawatts of
power of footprint of space and we
really depend on that for all of our
write operations and so that means the
durability of the data for example is
something that we can delegate down it
also means that we're in an environment
where we
and disaggregate compute from storage
right it gives us the ability to respond
to hot spots on one server by actually
picking that piece of indirectly picking
that piece of data up and moving it to
another server while leaving the storage
beneath fun little fact Colossus is
actually built recursively on top of
BigTable so this is a place where we're
reusing our infrastructure in order to
be able to scale it out the amount of
virtualization that's happening in our
infrastructure stack is pretty
astounding because again customers asked
me what happens when a disk fails and
I'm like I haven't thought about a disk
failure in I don't know how many years
so yeah and I think this is a you know
when I spoke earlier to now getting a
lot of visibility from everything from
the disk layer on up you know Google
actually you know builds its own disk
appliances right and we spend an
enormous amount of time thinking about
the availability of a desk appliance the
cost of a disk appliance how fast we can
execute our pcs against these things we
continually improve our efficiency and
effectiveness of those disk appliances
and we deploy them at massive scale and
it's sort of being able to have that
sort of incoming pipe of people working
on even that's the building raw
components that you're building these
systems on is just a it's an absolute
luxury yeah I think we're a hardware
company to is absolutely yeah
data center business so this is the
other part that we basically win on
which is true time so walk us through
this yeah so I can't be more excited to
show you this most boring rack you know
I think one of the most interesting
comments I usually get when people read
the spanner paper is they're like wow
atomic clocks and then you're like yes
you can get them on eBay they're they're
not as expensive as you think they are
this is actually our latest generation
so this is rolling out into the fleet
now you know the true time team is a
really small group this basically shows
a fairly standard configuration that we
have within a data center each one of
there are four time servers in here two
are connected out to the GPS antennas
that you see this provides a GPS
calibrated signal
two of the other remaining servers are
actually connected to two atomic
oscillators there are two different
brands of oscillators here so we get
different failure behaviors actually in
the same with the GPS cards as well and
this is connected into our fabrics and
what this does is it provides a really
accurate time signal with bounds and
this is sort of the principle upon which
spanner is built this idea of not just
saying a point in time but an interval
in time and what can we do with a very
highly reliable accurate interval of
time and that's what you're trying
provides and I can't speak exactly to
where we are now but it's sort of it
clearly less than a millisecond of drift
and there you go yeah this is one of the
cornerstones that allows us to be the
differentiated technology in terms of
external consistency and we'll get into
that but I think it's important to
understand that like it's not just about
atomic clocks and GPS but about the hard
work that goes into building these
systems and the infrastructure around
that okay so let's quickly touch upon
given those building blocks how does
spanner do a serve request rate what is
the life of a read and a write I am very
excited to say that and who actually
drew this by hand he's good with crayons
[Applause]
and his writing is remarkably good right
I I went to an engineering school so
yeah my kids actually helped me with
this it was great we did it this weekend
it turns out that you know even an
eight-year-old can design a distributed
system hers didn't look quite as good as
mine but we will take it so we do get a
lot of questions about you know how does
spanner work what is what is what
exactly happens when I issue a reader or
right so typically what I like to walk
people through is the life of a read and
the life of a write at kind of a high
level you can see it here I think it's
easier to start with the life of a write
we have a client these are typically in
a VM although they could be other places
they go to our load balancer
and from there they go to a front-end
which sends them on to the very first
fan server a spam server is what
actually stores a good description of
this slices of your data so we refer to
them as packs those groups these are
basically data containers that are
spread across multiple zones for
availability commits have to go to two
out of three or three out of five or
some number that forms a quorum as you
can see it here
you know the spam server and zone a will
take that right that it gets and it will
forward it on to Zone B and zone C it
will wait until two of those come back
to total come back both its local one
and one of the others and then it'll
return back to the client and that's the
point at which it becomes durable you
can see in reference here Colossus which
I mentioned earlier this is our big
distributed file system span servers we
run tons of them you know you know
internally spanner is heavily heavily
used so we're talking about you know
thousands to tens of thousands of these
running it in a data center your data
resides on a fraction of those before
you move on to the reads really quickly
just to level set because we live and
breed this so I like spanner is a
replicated synchronously replicated
database what that means is that we have
full copies of the data database data in
at least three if not more availability
zones the copies of data are in Colossus
which is the distributed file system
that under talked about and because we
have this disaggregated storage and
compute spans servers here are the
compute unit that act on the data so the
the the questions around well what
happens if a server goes down do you
have to reload all the data and memory
in a different server are kind of our
thousand L because this the data is
always in the storage layer and all
these compute units or span servers are
doing is being responsible for serving
the data right and so when Andrew talks
about sort of a client sends a write
what they're doing is they're saying
write key with value X
that means that there's an operation
that needs to happen in any one of the
compute units this is really important
really any one of the compute units can
pick it up we use Paxos to figure out
who the leader is we don't have a
concept of master and there's a paper
out on taxes essentially it's a group
consensus protocol that allows you to
choose at most one semantics essentially
for a given point in time or a given
sort of operation that summarized it
okay but I just want to make sure we
understand what we're talking yeah I
mean I think the other thing that's
happened a few other things that are
happening here is you know during writes
we do use true time to pick a time stamp
those time stamps are used to create an
ordering which we talk about as being
externally consistent right that means
that you know if you do two successive
operations they will get increasing time
stamps right so an operation that
happens after another operation by the
concept of time will actually happen
that way I think the other thing that's
kind of interesting from this diagram is
really to think about you know where
does high availability come from right
and high availability really comes from
the fact that we are replicating data
right so for example if his own sea
falls off the face of the map earthquake
California that sort of thing
we can still continue to issue rights to
zone a or zone B if we have a crashing
bug in one of the spam servers for
example the other ones can pick it up
and so you get high availability by
taking these components of kind of blast
radiuses and what happens when they fail
and making sure that you have other
things to capture them up yeah do you
want to walk through the read yeah a
read is also very simple
I drew it here showing that the reads
don't necessarily have to go to the
leaders in order to be strongly
consistent so client might do a read he
might go to one of the other replicas of
the individual group now when it gets
there he has this you know he basically
picks a time stamp which is what we call
now plus epsilon which is typically that
at a time at which we know no rights
that we could have seen we're committed
that front end will basically say okay
pass it on to a spam server dispensary
will say okay do I have all of the data
up to that time and if enough time has
passed because we're talking you know
order milliseconds and you know rights
may be going on he will actually just
return the date of day if he doesn't
have the data he'll reach out to the
leader and say dude I hear you have some
data for me and the spam server will say
yes here you go
either here's the data you need or you
actually have all the data I just
haven't told you that you have all the
data and in that case the read will be
performing locally yeah so I think the
point here that is different from other
systems is that we are in almost all
cases to serving the data from the local
replicas so we're not there other system
that ship buffers around when they're
replicated we are not tripping buffers
around right what we're saying is okay
what's the latest timestamp that I can
serve data at do I have it or not and if
the answer is yes that you have it then
you go serve it or you wait for the data
to be shipped as part of the paxos
protocols separately right so you're not
actually shipping megabytes and
megabytes and buffers around yeah and
just to give you an order on sort of the
timing here you could imagine that zones
a B and C or actually all within a
region in that case you know your rights
are on the order of you know five to ten
sort of milliseconds because that's a
quarter of what it takes to create a
quorum across those data centers for a
read it would be much much faster
because you're only reaching out to one
data center so once we get through the
load balancer and everything like that
it's I think it's on the three to five
by five range from from external cloud
yeah all right
so let's talk about some of the aha
moments where we well you at least chose
to be a systems guy sorry to a database
person from industry a systems person
right yeah I mean so I think you know
people say well what's what's great
about spanner what should I take away I
think there are two things that I
typically reference one is that as a
distributed systems engineer you're
grown-up and everybody tells you you
cannot trust time the clock on your
server is absolutely something
can't trust right and you develop sort
of this innate fear of that thing right
it's like legendary and you also sort of
probably experienced some really bad
things when you decide to trust time
anyways having the ability to actually
trust time and you know we are now 10
years later and I can tell you that I
completely trust our time system right
it has made my life so much easier
being able to basically have a source of
global ordering that I don't actually
have to reach out and talk to that I can
reference locally is a huge huge huge
just thinking shift and it took us
actually quite a long time to get over
that you know when I said we did two or
three versions of this system some of
the earlier ones actually worked more on
logical clock passing or figuring out
how to weave these things through and
weaving time stamps through your system
actually has some really bad effects
usually on your client you're like okay
well this person can give me a time
stamp now I can take this time stamp and
give it to someone else that means that
the application actually has to see it
and so being able to trust time and use
that in a way actually has really good
upper-level api effects as well the
second sort of aha moment was that we
spent a lot of time not implementing
transactions in BigTable
for a variety of reasons and the main
reason is is that the availability of
any one of our big table tablets was not
sufficient enough to support
transactions and so what Paxos and
groups bring us is they bring us highly
available participants so the other sort
of aha moment in here is you can do a
lot with highly available participants
you can trust them to be coordinators
you can trust them to hold locks you can
trust them to do things like that so
it's really the combination of both
trusting time and having highly
available components upon which to build
transactions that make spanner unique
yeah I remembered the good time of day
was an evil
you never put it in your code but true
time along with Paxos gives us that
external consistency of you can and I
love saying mr. customers because
they're like I don't believe you but you
can write from anywhere in the world
into a spanner database and you can
literally say I wrote like I incremented
my like bank account with 50 bucks and
anywhere in the world somebody can read
that timestamp and actually get an
answer for it was plus 50 which is an
amazing thing to have so 50 bucks okay
so let's move on to a little bit more on
the nostalgia piece which I find
exciting but we talked about sailing
systems but you also have to scale teams
yeah I mean I think you know every every
good project and you know I've talked to
some people or earlier there's sort of
small teams spanner of course started
with a small team right it started with
four people in an office I think this
picture is in 2012 it shows about five
or six people we look heavily engaged in
a particular event probably in terms of
a server going down or us debugging sort
of things it's kind of yeah so Chris is
down here in the front he looks much
younger in that photo there were less
critical systems running I think spanner
at the time and I also want you to talk
about this one yeah so this was my cube
mate this is Mike he he's a fan of ASCII
art these were our first hundred users
so you know every now and then you see
you know a $20 bill posted on on the
front of a deli or something like that
this this was our screen as we watched
internal users adopts banner and when we
hit a hundred on our lovely VT 320 here
we had a little a little party so I want
to have people look at this and then
this so a couple years later we're
getting a little bigger we added a few
fish into the mix as any good team has I
think are still kicking Andrew and I
commissioned this logo because of course
we were a service and we needed a
product you know and
the logo so we have this logo and if you
don't understand what that is it's
obvious this is a spanner turning Google
so and then yeah so this is actually a
couple years ago at this point I think
the key thing to take away from this is
is that building a distributed system
that is highly available and actually
has all of the features that that you
all know and love is actually a
relatively complex problem the other
thing that I've really grown to
appreciate is is that data based
problems and systems problems are
actually full stack problems right and
so you have to have the amount of
complexity that is in these systems now
is substantially more when we built GFS
in the early days which was our first
distributed file system we almost
decided not to do it because we thought
it was too complex and nothing complex
that complex would ever work it turns
out it's the simplest thing we've ever
built
and spanner spanner has many more pages
of complexity on it I think the other
thing you've seen this picture is this
enormous giant wrench in the background
that actually is used for trains so if
you ever need to change a train wheel we
have a wrench for you yeah we actually
have three of them cuz we don't we have
agreed yes we have three wrenches and
three different sites and I think that
the takeaway because we are highly
available yes replicated so the thing
for me was cuz you know I for me this
has also been a journey and you know
building teams to have that sort of
rigor and mindset when we're doing
infrastructure that we have to have like
we make no compromises we don't cut
corners and in the processes for around
that stuff is like it changes right like
five people the process that works with
five people which is not doing people to
say hey fix this bug versus you know 50
people versus more than 50 people is
different and so it's really been a an
exciting journey and Andrew is very and
I am as well very excited about you know
the culture and the team cohesion and
all those things and they're real things
like you really have to worry about
culture and
respect and all that stuff as you grow
people and of course we in case that
wasn't obvious we actually have spanner
people distributed in multiple areas too
so we have people in New York the
Seattle Kirkland area a good portion of
our operations staff is actually in
Sydney where they're just starting to
wake up and Boston and managing a large
team finding good chunks of work for
them is is definitely a challenge
yeah okay so let's go into the more fun
parts which is let's opinionate okay so
let's session about a few things that I
know customers have talked to me and I
know that you're also passionate about
so first of them is cap theorem so does
spanner break the cap theorem Andrew
this is a great question
you know I think for years I hated the
cap theorem then I started sharing an
office with Eric Brewer and he turns out
to be an absolutely nice guy so it's
great and I you know I think you know as
I talked it over with Eric Eric is the
author of the cat theory by the way also
wrote a paper on how spanner doesn't
break the cap here you know as like as
you talk to you with Eric but his real
point here is the cap theorem was really
designed to help you think and it's
really also designed for you to think
about the extremes right so it's really
about you know hundred percent
situations and in real life nothing is a
hundred percent and so when you really
look when we talked about things like
the building blocks that we have our
network file systems and various other
sorts of things
we're able to take things like
partitions which might be really common
in most people's networks or most
people's winds and say hey can we think
about these things different can we
actually look at the data and understand
how often partitions actually impact
things when a partition happens for
example does it also impact the end
application or you know would it
actually impact the quorum and so as you
start to look at these you know both
from a mathematical perspective the
probabilities but you also look at the
on-the-ground data
what you find is that partitions are
actually much much less likely than the
other sources of error in your system
and this is one of the arguments we made
about true time with it being more
accurate than cpu failures we can sort
of make it here it turns out that most
sources of unavailability in our system
have things to do with like users I
don't know how many mapreduces have been
run in the world that have taken down a
system they weren't supposed to they
have things to do with RS re teams you
know missing a comma turning it into a
period and something like that so it's
those sources an operator is actually
much much lower than the Newser error
those sorts of events happen much more
than partitions and so once you
basically say ok let's assume partitions
are not going to be the source of the
unavailability can you build a system
that actually has really good
availability and gives you consistency
and so that's sort of where we land yeah
so I think we are a wee trade-off
partition tolerance for availability
right mostly cool so the other
interesting thing here is you know
spanner evolved as a from a no sequel to
a BigTable world into a fully sequel
database and so you know how has your
thoughts on no sequel to three sequel
evolved
yeah so many years ago I was invited to
give a talk about no sequel I knew
nothing about no sequel so I went and
read Wikipedia like a good person and it
said you know a series of distributed
systems as created from the lineage of
BigTable I said oh okay I know BigTable
oh maybe I do know something about no
sequel typically when people talk about
no sequel they're talking about a
horizontally scalable key value system
right typically they also talk about
some properties around eventual
consistency I was for years a huge fan
of eventual consistency I built big
tables first replication system it was
eventually consistent I was totally
convinced that anybody who wouldn't want
an eventual e consistent system was
wrong I'm here to tell you I was wrong
on leaps and bounds yes what you sort of
learn over time with an eventually
consistent system is you actually go to
start to work with users right and you
see users try to build applications on
top and an eventually consistent system
yes it's kind of fun right we get to use
that part of our brain that creates a
complicated algorithm that only works
under these certain situations and maybe
the user sees it this way or maybe the
user doesn't see that way but at the end
of the day is just not really any fun
right and our goal is to build products
right our goal is not to build you know
complicated algorithms that you know fix
little edge cases right we want to get a
product in front of our customers we
want to see that product quickly and get
feedback on it right and consistent
systems give you that property you know
sort of had the same idea around
transactions you know the very first
version is a big table for example have
a complicated split and merged protocol
in them we kind of know what we were
doing we hand rolled their own
transactions I think we did it six times
because we got it wrong time after time
after time right
having primitives around consistency in
transactions as building blocks are
incredibly productive they let you sort
of leverage those things onto other
things I think you know the other thing
that you find in sort of this kind of no
sequel versus new sequel debate is
really this idea of sequel sequels great
I think it's a perfectly fine language
tuples are great
I think types are incredibly useful
we've seen systems on the key/value
space to adopt types more and more as we
start to think about moving compute
closer to the data which is a trend than
things databases have been doing closer
to here's you really need a language to
express that you need to understand
types so you can drive it down to the
processor level and so sequel is a great
language I think where sequel tends to
get a bad rap is it's often associated
with vertically scaled systems right
things that only fit in the box or you
know they have
challenges around multi-tenancy I think
spanner does a much better job on you
know the horizontal scaling aspect so
that gives us some power
we've also always run in a multi-tenant
environment Google has you know tens and
twenties and hundreds of thousands of
databases internally all competing for
the same resources so multi-tenancy has
been a core component of what we do for
years and so those sorts of properties
of sequel systems we we kind of can look
slightly differently totally so we
talked about consistency of you talked
about sequel no sequel how do you think
it kind of comes together to power
Google's cloud offerings right yeah so
you know I think there's you know
spanner is a is a workhorse right we use
it in many many different ways at Google
we use it both for things of scale right
so things that are petabytes that look
you know kind of like traditional
indexing and batch workloads we use it
for very critical high availability
loads I was just at a talk right before
this where it was performance
benchmarking around VM boot up times
right and was talking about the
complexity programming the control plane
that control plane is done in spanner
right so our ability to spin things up
quickly and have them highly available
is dependent on the spanner we see it in
sort of the you know SAS application
space right where you might take
something like Gmail where it takes a
whole bunch of users Maps them into a
single database and gives them power
that way and we also see it in very
traditional database workloads we use it
for some of our capacity planning for
example or capacity delivery systems and
so we really have a workhorse of a
system that really goes from everything
from the very big to the very small lot
of a lot a lot a lot of small use cases
that are all using spanner
for its manageability and scale
insurance and all that stuff
so and it's also probably a good time I
know Deepti mentioned it earlier which
is tomorrow
my colleague Dennis from the GCS team
which is our Google Cloud Storage is
going to present how GCS uses spanner
for its metadata so our really large
scale systems are actually built with
spanner as its backbone yeah that's
gonna be spanner internals bar - yes
tomorrow morning so come watch us but
yeah you know it's cool to see both the
GC s's and the Gmail's as well as the
drives and a bunch of other small
internal systems like supply chain
management you spanner alright so these
are some of the headlines for when we
launched spanner they were more
controversial ones with anything put
here but you know I know both you and I
have thoughts on sort of why we launched
it externally so you know why don't you
yeah I mean I you know I think one of
the great things about why I'm excited
about cloud its new workloads you know I
mentioned you know why I get excited
about infrastructure it's because
there's new challenges new workloads new
customers I was very excited to see
examples of workloads that I saw
internally externally I can think
spanner is a great building block for a
lot of applications being able to get
that out to you all and have you working
into your systems was a big win for me
yeah I think it was a while before we
could convince ourselves that we wanted
to be a public product primarily because
we didn't think that externally people
had the same challenges that we had
internally and I remember sort of doing
a whole initial program of going out
there and talking to customers to see
what was like whether this would be a
useful system for them because at the
time this is like three years ago which
is dog years in cloud world when we're
trying to launch pianore we're cognizant
that people you know don't want just
another cool tech because Google built
it right it's especially on the
databases side like people want
something that solves their problems and
is this something that is going to solve
their problem or not so we actually
wanted to be Congress sort of user
issues and see if this could solve you
know our user and customer pain points
and
after serving customers we we found that
you know customers were coming to this
with the new internet age of everything
connected everything always on
everything online customers wanted that
kind of stale and scale insurance with
horizontal scalability and strong
consistency and relational semantics and
so it was like a really good time to to
be their public eye so thank you so much
for your time again
[Music]